hi guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to talk about vitamin E in
coronary heart disease okay now there
are studies out there that will show
that vitamin E causes coronary heart
disease and there's studies that show
that it actually will clear coronary
heart disease well what they failed to
tell you is the unless you read the fine
print is that the ones that show that
vitamin E causes heart disease are
always using a synthetic vitamin E
they're not using a natural vitamin E
it's always synthetic so that's a big
factor because apparently synthetics
don't work for heart disease okay
doesn't prevent any heart disease
situations might be good for other
things but not definitely not the heart
so vitamin E in nature always comes in a
complex with many different parts this
is the vitamin E complex yes it has the
decoff roles which are the antioxidant
Porsche parts which is the alpha beta
Delta Gamma but it also has another
factor called
xanthine selenium a mineral Lippa cells
f2 f12 III fractions all these different
component parts it doesn't come as one
thing so when you take that one version
you're only getting a very Porsche a
small portion of the vitamin E complex
the key that I'm going to talk about the
most important thing I want to talk
about is this getting a natural version
you want to get the version if you
actually buy it from the store somebody
else says tocotrienols okay tocotrienols
are the natural version that you want to
get and if you get the ones that have
the Alpha and the beta two gamma and the
Delta and one complex you're getting a
better version because these are fat
soluble these are vitamin E in general
is a fat soluble vitamin which means it
penetrates the cell wall and that's what
it will do it penetrates the plaque in
the arteries and it helps dissolve the
plaque it also decreases platelets from
forming that form the clot in the first
place it also will help you prevent the
oxidation of cholesterol so vitamin E is
very important in preventing the clot
formation which also could lead to
drugs all right the other point I want
to make about vitamin E is that yes it's
true it comes from grains whole grains
but as soon as they grind the grain and
make it into flour it oxidizes from
oxygen and it gets destroyed pretty
quick so when you buy bread or even
whole wheat from the store you're buying
bread from flour that can been sitting
on the shelf for six months to a year
so normally you probably are not going
to have time to grind your grain and
make the bread even though it's even
high in sugar the whole thing but you if
you were to take whole grain and grind
it and make your bread you would get
some vitamin E but there's much better
ways to get your vitamin E so here's a
question how do I get my vitamin E what
foods do I eat that's a really good
question I'm glad you asked number one
wheat germ but the problem with wheat
room is it's either roasted or if it's
raw wheat germ it's rancid because it's
sitting on the shelf for a long time so
that's probably not the best idea you
can get it from palm oil you can get it
from nuts or you can get it from this
right here lettuce
so just so happens that lettuce has a
lot of vitamin E and this is another
reason why you need to eat large salads
right I mean I will I will do a huge
salad and I'll probably do half of this
and one salads okay in summary the next
time you get a vitamin E make sure it's
a natural version make sure it's in the
complex and really start eating your
salads alright thanks for watching